Daily Mail reports federal agents have
enough evidence to charge Hunter Biden
with tax crimes and making false
statement while buying gun bombshell
report claims decision lies in the hands
of U.S attorney in Delaware in Delaware
perfect they know all about the bidens
I'm sure we're going to see Hunter held
to account and then hey man The Dominoes
begin falling because once they get
Hunter he's going to squeal like a pig
and he's gonna be like my dad did it all
he's a pedo he's pedo Peter here's the
laptop here's proof and then Joe Biden's
going down mark my words on November
12th they're the arrests are no
nothing's gonna happen I haven't quite
literally nothing's gonna happen Hunter
Biden's gonna laugh at it Joe Biden's
gonna do nothing and even if they did
charge Hunter Joe Biden would be like
here's a here's a blanket pardon son
free to go yeah I thought you were
reading the latest cue drop there for a
second
this I think is a way to scare Americans
into paying their taxes and not buying
guns I think they're gonna make Hunter a
poster boy for tax evasion and gun
illegal gun handling they're going to
give them a slap on the wrist but enough
that's like people don't are super
afraid they don't want to cross the
government because the government is
looking out for tax and gun crimes that
is interesting because of all the things
they could have got him on to choose
those things I mean those are relatively
minor crimes compared to everything that
he's done with human trafficking crack
all that's the the deals with China tax
evasion buying a gun that's that seems
odd yes common of course they want to
scare people with it right now and
they're they're willing to throw Hunter
under the bus whoever they are but like
you said Biden could pardon the guy he
probably won't he's probably gonna be
like well he needs to you know we got to
make an example out of Hunter but you'll
be okay no he'll do it he'll just pardon
him straight up yeah because Joe is not
going to be in I don't believe Joe would
be was going to run for president in
2024. he's going to be like I'm out I
don't care
if he pardons him it will set an example
that like paying your taxes isn't that
important you think he cares about that
no one no one else yeah I think he's
obsessed with making people pay taxes
right now that's why he hired
gonna make an example this is my my
projection is he'll make an example out
of Hunter these people are minor
directions this guy is so dirty and
corrupt well he's not going to nail him
he's just gonna you know banish him like
he's a 17 year old Hunter Biden could
destroy the Biden family with everything
he knows Joe is going to give him
everything he wants I think I think
Hunter's in it I think Joe will be like
we're gonna make an example out of you
to show people that paying taxes is
important I was like okay Dad you think
that is going to be like sure thing Dad
no he's gonna be like no I'm not doing
that because he'd go don't make me go
and talk to them because I'll tell them
what you did with Ukraine and China but
he'd go down with him if he did if
Hunter turned on Joe they'd both go down
Hunter's too self-serving I don't I
don't know if he's gonna go to prison
and Joe won't pardon him then I'll say
if I'm going down I'm taking you with me
I mean maybe he'll get like 60 days time
served in a in a cushy home arrest yeah
that that bracelet the gun charge I'd be
surprised but yeah if they give him
house arrest he'd probably be like sure
thing pop yeah doing crackiness well
this is this is this sorry Hunter man
this is the same guy that had Secret
Service intervene when his gun was found
in a trash can in 2018. Secret Service
literally butted in and said oh no this
is a local police case we're gonna make
sure we're involved in this and and they
literally found a handgun
that was registered to him in a trash
can which is like and he got away with
it yeah yeah hold on hold on they're
saying they might charge him so not for
that specific charge what is it for
example he might he might not I mean
there's talks about this uh what is it
attorney general or uh prosecutor
there's talks about this prosecutor
being uh right wing and there's a
possibility of this happening I think
yeah it's a trump prosecutor yeah that
was appointed by him so people are
saying there's a small possibility here
but again the system has a way of
greasing the wheels here Joe Biden is an
extremely dirty human being that will
use every illicit means to of course
protect his inner circle and
um I could see a lot of shadowy things
happening behind the scenes putting
pressure on this prosecutor being like
this is my son you don't do this and
then the prosecutor's saying okay sure
do you think Hunter caves on his dad I
think I think there's a theory out there
that I think is plausible of Hunter
deliberately releasing a lot of this
stuff in order to get back at his dad
for a potential crimes that Hunter
committed against the president Hunter
might actually be the hero yeah you know
he's like sitting there and he's being
like I want to be a crackhead but for
the American people I'll make the
sacrifice he's good friends he's good
friends with Tucker Carlson what Hunter
yes look up Hunter Biden Tucker Carlson
you could see it they have a good
relationship with each other so maybe
potentially yeah
he's like giving all this information up
for money that's that's you know that
makes more sense to me uh money but also
maybe retribution maybe there's there's
something he calls his dad a pedo
apparently yeah that's listed as a
contact I could see like in 15 or 20
years after Joe Biden's passed away that
Hunter is like does a tell-all story
where he's like he was abusive he was
manipulative he got me involved in
Ukraine uh he put me in positions that I
didn't want to be you know just
demonizing look how horrible it was big
sympathy for Hunter Hunter runs for
office the Biden name you know bull like
crap like that I can see I don't know
the by name is synonymous with mud at
this point because of like just
everything wrong with the economy this
is funny if you look at the polling for
Democrats the generic ballot they're
they're polling tracks alongside gas
prices to a certain degree now that gas
prices are going up Democrat polling is
going down because they're the ones who
are in charge and when gas prices go up
this is most people it really is simple
math most people don't know don't care
Russia nuclear war or whatever but I
tell you this you probably go to your
your friends your family and you're like
hey this nuclear war stuff is serious
they could you know we can go to war
people could die and they're going I
don't know what you're talking about I
don't care about that and you're like
your gas prices are up 50 cents well
hold on what I noticed that and I'm mad
it's because of Joe Biden's war in
Ukraine and I say Joe Biden's War
because I fully understand that Vladimir
Putin invaded Ukraine but Joe Biden
decided to involve the U.S in something
that doesn't involve us so that is his
War you can blame a lot on Putin but why
are we involved so if you want to talk
to people and you want to convince them
to pay attention to this you can be like
hey you know your gas is going up
because of this and that means you can't
pay your rent you're not gonna be able
to buy food it means food costs are
going to go up labor costs are going to
go up and you can thank Joe Budden well
he's burning through our our strategic
oil reserves right now too I mean oh
yeah man he's just he's just holding off
until the election as soon as the
election is over gas prices are going to
Skyrock because uh you know I don't know
how much reserves we have left but I
think we're at a kind of a record low so
8.80 gas and in California last week
yeah hell it was 89 cents when I was
when I was like 18. I mean if you're if
you're looking to have some kind of
large reformatting
an impactful new beginning but we're
still going to deal oil even if there's
a gray reset we still need oil if they
cut off the oil I think like billions
will die like within the first few days
of oil getting cut off 60 million I
think are the estimates between 20 and
60 minutes dude I'm looking at this
technology where a guy puts oil in his
like deoxygenated pressure chamber or to
puts plastic rather in his deoxygenated
pressure chamber and then turns it back
into oil and then can reuse the oil like
what kind of plastic and is the video
fake it was like a Japanese guy from
like six or seven years ago and it was
in a small scale man I saw a video of a
guy levitating objects and perpetuals it
was pretty basic and I think it's still
to be refined re-refined to be able to
use like gasoline but it was oil I think
people need to understand too like P
people like Greta tunberg when she's
like we have to stop the fossil fuels
now you need to imagine an iron gauntlet
on her hand and her slamming the table
because she's talking about killing
people yes Mass genocide's called like
cutting off fossil fuels abruptly and
outright will just kill tens of millions
instantly and then within a few days
well they already known it with famine
you know that's but but give it a few
years and then there's going to be
famines power shortages and you're gonna
see look take a look at the population
growth charts and then right around the
Advent of fossil fuels it just goes
straight up it goes from like a
consistent 500 million people in the
world throughout history and then right
before the turn of the century it just
jumps to the billions and then it keeps
climbing exponentially and it's because
of this massive energy rich product if
you cut that off it's going to go right
back down here's the video it's called
Uh Bill Gates is like yes yes finally
that's why it keeps trying this is
called machine reverts plastic back to
oil it's new inventions machine reverts
plastic back to oil it's from about 11
years ago and the the name that the
inventor is akinori Ito he was the CEO
of
blessed.co.ltd at the time the website
now that link is no longer working I
don't know what the status of this
technology is right now but I mean if
one guy in a small company can make this
on a small scale where's our industrial
plastic recycling we got a CBC report
apparently they're doing it big pile of
trash and these tiny pieces of plastic
is what you're talking about I'm not
sure no this is a Canadian company says
they figured how to do it that would be
a diesel fuel that we're getting out of
here wow
gasoline from plastic this is the two
that we've set up to do plastic is just
like oil and it came out of the ground
at one time the same way we are taking
plastic and we are we are converting it
using a process called pyrolysis where
we're converting it into a fuel fuel so
we know that Bill Gates has people who
monitor conversations about him so you
know of course when the show starts they
tell them uh Mr Gates Tim cast IRL is on
well turn it on the TV and now he's
watching and he sees this clip and he
goes what and he's like slamming the
table and he's gonna call he's like shut
him down we don't want people to live
you solved my problem
no no no no no no his problem isn't the
use of fossil fuels his problem is that
the use of fossil fuels makes more
people thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there